you
[Applause]
Kathy Griffin is recently getting some
heat for her Donald Trump stunt that she
did as a comedian when do you feel like
you know that you've crossed that line I
think that it is the job of a comedian
to cross the line at all times because
you know that's that line is not real
and if you step out into that spotlight
and you're doing the crazy things that
he's doing you know we're the last line
of defense and really the comedians are
the last the last voice of truth in this
whole thing you know and you know it's
impossible to get away from it you know
I had to dream the other night about
that I was playing golf with Donald
Trump and I was standing beside him with
a club in my hand I was you know
considering my options when I suddenly
woke up you know it was one of those
dreams when you want to just get back to
sleep so you can finish it you know but
I've taken up golf anyway et spoke with
Kerry at the premiere of the new
Showtime series he's executive producing
I'm dying up here centered around the
world of stand-up comedy so much you
kill time let you bond that was the
Hiroshima a bombing this shows is what
I've wanted to do for a very long time
and some nights I go to the store and
I'd be a king and the next night I would
you know be experimenting in bomb so
badly that I have to crawl into the
piano for the next four act so there's
all kinds of little pieces of my life in
this thing I mean you know from living
in a closet to you know waking up the
first morning in my new house with girl
cooking bacon with no pants on I mean it
was it's been an odyssey
[Music]
you